. I truly am unsure how to introduce this
next story, but it is one of the craziest
side stories of the 2020 campaign. Donald
Trump's personal lawyer, Rudy Giuliani,
the guy who brought us the Hunter Biden story has
been caught either. And again, we don't yet know
masturbating or trying to have sex with Borat's
daughter from the second Borat film by Sacha
Baron Cohen, which comes out tomorrow. Now,
that explanation may be even more confusing.
Borat's daughter, Borat's a character. What
do I mean, Borat's daughter? That's what
makes explaining this story very difficult.
Actor and comedian Sacha Baron Cohen has a
character he does called Borat Sagdiyev, who was
the star of the first Borat movie some years ago
and in the last six to 12 months, 18 months.
Sacha Baron Cohen has been filming the sequel to
that film, and that comes out tomorrow on Amazon
Prime video in the process of filming this movie,
Borat and his daughter, meaning an actress playing
his daughter, invited Rudy Giuliani to meet for an
interview as part of the film. And again, this
is sort of straddling fiction and nonfiction,
as Sacha Baron Cohen often does in the sense
that some of the people interviewed or featured
in the film are being pranked, essentially
not realizing they're in a fiction movie. And
this situation ultimately led to a hotel room
where the woman playing Borat's daughter, who
Rudy Giuliani apparently believes is a right wing
journalist, removes Rudy Giuliani's microphone,
at which point Rudy Giuliani leans back in the
bed and. Puts his hand in his pants and and again,
there is debate as to exactly what was going
on, at which point Sacha Baron Cohen runs in
and yells, she's 15, she's too old for you. Now,
the actress is Maria Baklava. She's reportedly
24 years old, as far as we know. Not actually a
15 year old. We first heard a rumor about this
back in July when Rudy Giuliani reported it to
the police, supposedly saying at the time, quote,
This guy comes running in wearing a crazy what I
would say was a pink transgender outfit. It was
a pink bikini with lace underneath a translucent
mesh top. It looked absurd. He had the beard, bare
legs and wasn't what I would call distractingly
attractive. This person comes in yelling and
screaming. And I thought, this must be a scam or
a shakedown. So I reported it to the police. He
then ran away. That's what Rudy told The New York
Post back in July. Now, at the time, Rudy did not
say that he did anything inappropriate. Now we are
getting more of the story. And this is, of course,
insanely embarrassing for Rudy Giuliani.
We still don't have the full story. Rudy,
during the course of this interview, reportedly
also agrees to eat a bat with Maria Baklava,
who again is playing Borat's daughter. Rudy is
reportedly drinking throughout the interview. He,
which is very well known to do, he's also
reportedly coughing throughout the interview.
And this was filmed during the Corona virus
pandemic. So just like every detail is as crazy
as it could be, Rudy involved in this incident
during a pandemic and he's again, reportedly,
we'll see tomorrow coughing throughout the thing
based on the reports about this from July. There
was no indication that this was this embarrassing.
And the most unbelievable part of this is Rudy
Giuliani last night finally tweeted about it and
he's fully doubling down, saying it's all fake.
You mean you just have to see it. This is a four
tweet series. The first tweet is, quote, The Borat
video is a complete fabrication. I was tucking in
my shirt after taking off the recording equipment
at no time before, during or after the interview
was I ever inappropriate. If Sacha Baron Cohen
implies otherwise, he is a stone cold liar. Now,
I've never seen someone tuck their shirt in in the
way that Rudy Giuliani is tucking his shirt in.
In the picture that we're showing the audience,
I might almost find it more believable if Rudy's
explanation was no. I had a Bible in my pants
and I was swearing on it. That's why my
hand was in my pants. But I guess this is
the story Rudy is going with. And when the film
comes out tomorrow, I presume we'll know more
about whether this explanation is even remotely
believable. Now, there are people who are saying,
you know, this is really no big deal. This is
this is the left shaming Rudy for trying to have
what is, by all into accounts, a consensual sexual
liaison. It's a private matter. The actress was
fictionally fifteen. In reality, it was a 24 year
old woman. But for me, the biggest takeaway is
Rudy admits he may have worked with a Russian spy
on the Hunter Biden story. And Rudy and everybody
around him wants us to believe that he would
never fall for a honey pot. He would never fall
for four foreign disinformation. He would never
be manipulated. This situation for which Rudy.
Rudy fell is so cartoonishly absurd that we need
to recognize when Rudy and others say, listen,
we're all too smart to fall for tricks. We're not
going to fall for the Hunter Biden story because
Russians tricked us or we were setup and that
would never happen. Just look at this situation
and look at Rudy admitting that it's 50/50, that
he worked with a Russian spy on the hundred Biden
story. And we're supposed to believe Rudy has
any wits about him. And it's just absolutely
ridiculous. And there are some who are saying
this is the end of Rudy Giuliani's career, period.
Others who are saying this is really nothing.
And once the video comes out, it will be clear
that this is no big deal. Let's wait
and see. We will see very, very soon.